my bad rosebud Australians aren't racist
but for a population of 20 million and a
landmass the size of the USA we have
bumper stickers that say God we're full
Australians aren't racist but even
though we openly call Americans Yanks
Englishmen Pommies and Pakistani pakis
and anyone who vaguely looks
Mediterranean a WoG we would never ever
shorten the word Aboriginal publicly
Australians aren't racist but even
second-generation Chinese Australians
avoid first generation Chinese
barristers unless they have tattoos cuz
you know if they've got ink the coffee's
good to drink Australians aren't races
but Iggy Azalea Australians aren't
racist but from 1901 to 1970 we had a
series of laws restricting the
immigration of people darker than the
color unwashed beige known collectively
as the White Australia Policy it's true
Australians aren't racist but Aboriginal
people who lived on the land for 40,000
years got the boat in 1967 and still
they want to be recognizing the
Constitution what else they want a life
expectancy on par with everyone else
Australians aren't racist but a popular
anti-immigration phrases we grew here
you flew here said usually by people
whose parents came to Australia by boat
it's just very catchy Australia's aren't
racist but as a kid I ate biscuits
called golliwogs
candy called Redskins and topped my
toast with a cheese called Coon nothing
beats Coon invented by a guy from
Philadelphia incidentally Edward could
that was his name it's true sorry
Australians aren't racist but the
English hated the Chinese during the
gold rush then the English and the
Chinese headed the post-war Greeks and
Italians then the Greeks Italians
Chinese and English hated the Lebanese
then the Lebanese greater towns Chinese
and English headed the Vietnamese then
the Vietnamese Lebanese Greeks it turns
Chinese and English head of the Indians
than any invent and his Lebanese Greeks
of tens of Chinese and English hey to
the Sudan X now Australia is a continent
filled with every nation on earth
who all hate each other equally
but still no one wants to talk about
aboriginals just don't know how other
than that Australia's not a racist
country my countries are bad racist but